[Music]
my name is Giles Fraser I'm vicar in
elephant Castle parish in South London
and and I write for unheard and so how
long have you been in elephant castle oh
seven seven seven years so yet I like
you very much
it's a fantastic place I came from
simples Cathedral beforehand which was
grand and fancy and I really like being
at the elephant cost so I have a very
diverse congregation probably just about
black majority church majority of my
parishioners are Ghanaian or Nigerian
that sort of thing and high church
smells and bells Anglican vicar and I
love it
that's what I do and is the area a
changing quite a lot oh my word is it
changing Daniel you've got my cup of
coffee that's why I was outside that's
why I really want your eyes is it
changing its changing enormous Lee and
it's a it's an area where people have
come and gone for for four years so
there's there's there's lots of new
communities that spring up all the time
I mean it's not politics that provides
communities that it's sort of people
it's not a top-down thing it's something
that sort of it emerges organically from
within forever within the space in which
people live and it requires people to
live in a particular space over time
over a certain period of time have a
sense of knowing their neighbors knowing
people around them having their children
live there or all of that sort of those
things that knit people together that's
what's required when you get rid of all
of that through rapid social change then
everybody's reliant on the state and the
state isn't as good well the state's not
as good at caring for you as your mum
and dad aha your or your neighbors are
or your churches or you know those sorts
of things so I mean the state obviously
has a terribly important role it does
have an important role and I and I and I
mean I've I'd have a much I'd have a
much bigger role for the state than the
IAEA would but nonetheless you know what
you're missing when the community goes
you certainly realized that actually all
those things that you take for granted
in terms of care when they're lost you
really notice them so it's it's it's an
interesting place you you have this sort
of great diversity and energy but also
there's sort of pockets of loneliness
and desperation and I mean I live on top
of the ayah live literally on top of the
northern light and people go through I
can hear it and we sit I sit in church
and I can hear the Northern Line
underneath the church and thousands of
people millions of people go through the
elephant costume every day but I also
know those people who don't see anybody
you know for whom those sorts of it's
just asset rands Ettore movement and
nothing can those sorts of patterns of
care are a very weak that's a problem
and do you see it as part of your role
then too
be a critic of the state or is the
church sort of an area which should be
separate sort of like
it shouldn't be tarnished by the dirty
politics but church is always don't
tarnish by dirty politics I mean it's
and I mean I don't I think the church is
inescapably political I think it's
messages in this guy could be political
but I I don't I mean I personally don't
think that there should be things like
bishops in the House of Lords or I don't
think we should be alloyed with a stated
institutional level and I think that
actually blunts a radical message
sometimes we I think the Church of
England is too easily conscripted by the
establishment and it's sort of can to
easily become courtiers to the state I
felt a bit like that it's imposed I felt
like I was a a courtier and and I think
that I think the church sells its self
too cheap when it does that but
definitely political definitely
plentiful and how so how did you feel
like that at some polls what were the
what you were pulling this profit
straight well no it's not no it's never
done you know it's never done as
directly as putting the puppet strings
but there is that sort of dressing up
and wandering around view of religion
which is ceremonial and state focused
and in the end it just becomes a little
bit too naturally bit too easy and
you're sort of patterns of thought gets
shaped by being too close to the
establishment and it's too comfortable
and so that's the problem with it where
the church having its worst I think is
it's too comfortable but the the glory
of the church England is these parishes
and and and the and the and the
communities that it works and it works
in every community in the land you know
and that's a and that's a really
important aspect of the Church of
England's work
I wonder if you could talk about the
reasons you had to leave simples and if
that has left you feeling it doesn't
sound like it but feeling tarnished by
the church or by the role of the church
well I left suppose because we disagreed
about how to address the issue of the
Occupy movement that came seven years
ago a long time ago and my colleagues
thought that I mean the the dividing
line between us is that my colleagues
decided that eviction which the right
thing to go for including the eviction
with right police which is the end or
what happened and I thought that that
should not be done in the name of the
church I was dead against that I also
thought missing may be separate I also
thought that the Occupy movement raised
really important matters of public
concern and they were doing it I mean
you know that the idea that people were
started to talk about economics in the
pub you know this was good this was
really really good and for all this sort
of you know there were those who
criticized the Occupy movement saying
that their message was unclear or or
wasn't okay but it was a it was it was a
space for conversation and it definitely
galvanized conversation and it affected
the church as well I mean I think I did
a little sort of unscientific survey
about the sermons on Christmas Day by
bishops after the Occupy thing which
happened in October and they were that
almost all of them referenced economics
in some way in a way that they've never
done before and the Archbishop of
Canterbury Justin Welby who's himself
worked in business I mean he said to me
that he didn't think he would have been
on Archbishop of Canterbury had it not
been for the Occupy movement so it had
it had it had a serious effect on the
church by camping outside support
certainly had a serious effect on me
and is it hard to do you have a strong
sense of your own faith within the
church that it there is times when it
separates
I mean I'm quite party sort of church
person really I mean I for all its
faults I love the Church of England and
I'm I'm glad I'm within the church in I
mean I really genuinely do and I I
wouldn't be in it otherwise but that's
not to say that you don't fall out and
have rounds like you do with anybody
that you love and there's things about
it that you wish were different but I
still think it plays such a play it
articulates Christianity in a way that I
I share I it it gets it right for me on
so many levels
but you know so I'm cheesed off with it
on
I was cheesed off I was very cheesed off
with it about occupy yeah and do you
think that that was quite a reactionary
situation in which occupy were bicycles
but do you think the church could do
more to support movements like this but
in an act
I mean the thing is when we talk about
church in politics the job of the church
is to proclaim the Gospel okay it's
religious it's this is a religious
organization and and there are all sorts
of ways in which social movements say
things that the church will agree with
extinction rebellion may well be a case
in point so but they're not the same
thing
you know when they they shouldn't ever
be confused and the job of the church
isn't to be political per se the job of
the church is to proclaim the gospel but
the gospel is political
it just keeps inescapably son and so you
know that there's sort of but there are
points in which some of these new social
movements are aligned you know you could
have are allied with the church in some
ways but they're not that they should
never be confused and the church and the
church shouldn't over invest in in
social movements like that
and moving on to your Eve done some work
on nature and the pious nature
yeah years ago yes would you be able to
explain what the how you can seen each
owner pious work in a pious way yeah
oh well that's that is quite interesting
so neat nature so Nietzsche came from a
very long line of clergy his dad was
Warren his you know grandfathers and
going back there was loads of them his
dad died when he was quite young and he
was brought up by his mum and sisters in
a you know in a very sort of piety he
won Nietzsche won the University
preaching prize you know this is and
then all of that and it I mean when he
sort of became an atheist and a
campaigning atheist the really
interesting thing about his atheism was
that it's there was a sort of piety
about it there was a sort of the world
depends on this
almost almost your salvation depends on
this I mean obviously in a secular way
but you know the question of God became
a question of real importance Tim and
and in fact for me that was one of the
things that was really instrumental in
my conversion to Christianity so I went
to university fairly straightforward
atheist and Nietzsche and others
Kierkegaard and a few others but they
raised the question of God in such a way
that I thought I had to give it an
answer it would suddenly this was an
important I suddenly realised why the
question was important whereas before I
didn't even think the question was
important
that's what of atheist that's the real
atheism by the way indifference is the
real that's the real atheism the Dawkins
type of atheism that's that's not it
that's fine that's always it that's a
tiny flip away from Christianity but
indifference that's that that's the
thing that Christians should be most
afraid of and Nietzsche and it was
absolutely not indifferent you know this
is he raised the question of God in such
a way that I knew
something really serious depended upon
how I answered it so that was the
beginnings of my sort of struggle with
Christianity and for years and people
you say about me Oh John's got this
weird hobby you know Java is weird hobby
he's like he's interested in religion
you know and he reads all that stuff on
the side and I did and it was a for a
long time it was a sort of quite an
academic but Nietzsche is a sort of
academic II writer per se who's too
passionate for that but for a while it
was that for me and then somehow I
realized that I wasn't on the outside
looking in but I was on the inside
looking out and it had shaped my world
and I knew that that's what I had to do
and I still feel I still feel the same
way about it as I did when I I guess
conversion is them would and what was it
about those thinkers that made you
realize the importance of it was it like
their passion or the passion is of
arguments what passion is is an aspect
of it but it was also a way of seeing
the world and and and whereas before I'd
have looked at the world and the
question of God was not raised by the
world I looked at after reading all that
sort of stuff I'd look at the sort of
you know this beautiful scene and I
would go there's something about is this
which is asking me a question which I'd
never before and funnily enough it's the
persistence of the question that in the
end the end makes you see the world
differently you know it's not very very
few people that argued into faith and in
fact that's why much to atheists
frustration that's why people can't be
argued out of it either you know you
don't get argued in out of something you
never argued you know so it's more like
falling in love you know and you can
fall out of love and so there is a
process but but but it isn't quite so
susceptible to rational argument as many
a
presume so they're quite frustrated they
think they've won the argument but why
is nothing happened with the person they
think they've won the argument with and
that's sort of because they're missing
what it is that's charging the Christian
vision and is that not also he said that
new atheism is an atheist and it's not
indifferent are they also tackling with
looking at the world and yes it's just
no I mean new a new atheism is a very
interesting phenomena I mean I have all
sorts of problems with it but in one way
much much more like Christianity than
either side would feel comfortable with
actually you know that as I said
indifference is is the thing that is the
real killer but but I mean lots of new
atheists passionately engaged with this
with beauty of the world with with the
nature of justice with the nature of
what is right with the nature of the
meaning of life the universe and
everything and all that sort of stuff
I I to my taste in argumentative terms
it's more flat-footed than it used to be
I mean I think you know Nietzsche's
Nietzsche hated Christianity he didn't
just think it was wrong he thought it
was wicked and that there was a sort of
something that and he also realized
Nietzsche did and I think that new
atheists don't get this
Nietzsche realize that the most
important question is not the question
about whether God exists then the most
important question is sort of the
question of personal salvation is that
how do I fit into this sort of a vikin
and how is this broken person somehow or
the languages saved you know now that
the idea that religion begins with the
question of salvation something that
Luther for instance would be would would
be terribly important to and a Nietzsche
was a sore loser and minister so
Nietzsche asked the question of
salvation and answered it by your saved
by being an atheist
okay that's sort of it the New Atheists
not interested in that question they
really only want to know whether there
is a thing up there called God or is
there not a thing up that cooker they
think that's the nature of the argument
and I'm less interested in that question
and people think I should be actually
you know that's not that's not the thing
that keeps me awake at night and how how
why is there so much indifference
nowadays then and how would you see that
you can sort of tackle that indifference
I suspect that there was some connection
between indifference and individualism I
suspect that the sort of cultural
patterns in which Christianity work of a
conducive to Christianity were within a
sort of thick sense of community as I
talked about before and that tends to be
the case that religion and community in
Islam in Judiasm religion works with I
think as as we have become more
individuated as a as a society I think
that religion finds is less to grab on
to
and and I think that's also true despite
the fact that Protestantism was one of
the reasons that individuated us so this
sort of idea that it's all about your
individual commitment to God rather than
your corporate membership of the church
and that is that is a part of them
historical process by which either they
of the rise of the individual that in
capitalism and other things but but I
think I think probably that's that's the
connection something between faith and
community communities at faith for me is
a corporate experience it's it's
something about the priority of the we
over the priority of the I and about and
it's embedded in that sense of we there
was a there's a story I've told her a
couple of times is when I had to do a
terror
all funeral when I was quite young as a
priest and I sort of lost my faith it
was a child whose funeral of a child
renews and and I was a vicar in a black
country in the West Midlands and big
cold empty Church it was a horrible
experience and four days afterwards I
thought this is all rubbish
you know I just come out of university
I'm sort of fresh with ideas but the
reality of it thought this was rubbish
and but I'm the vicar so I have to go to
church on Sunday morning and my job is
to I can't say I'm not getting up this
morning I don't believe in it and I'd
stand there you say the Creed and I
swing realised the beginning of the
kree's we believe in God the Father
Almighty correctly and I thought
actually I'm a part of this group of
people I want to be a part I'm in this
group of people and at the moment you're
doing the believing for me and I'm
rather grateful of that and that was a
that lasted ER and number of months but
it gave me a much greater sense that
somehow your faith is sustained by other
people
you're carried by other people even
intellectually even when you can't add
it up make sense of it so now I do have
a very strong corporate sense of the
church and the need for the church
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV
you